Well, today, we're learning
that President Biden's
legal team
found another batch
of classified documents.
A source
saying these documents came in searches
that began after the November discovery
of the classified dogs from president.
Now, President
Biden's time as vice president
and an old office in Washington, D.C.
So the question really is
what does this mean for the president?
How are we just now learning about this
and also the DOJ going forward?
Joining me now, CNN special correspondent
Jamie Gangel,
CNN senior law enforcement
analyst Andrew McCabe, and CNN
legal analyst Elliot Williams.
I'm glad you're all here.
And I bet
we have similar questions
as to who, what, when,
the question of who knew what, when, why.
But I want to begin with you, Jamie,
because there is we don't know.
Well, there we go to that
end of the segment today.
Thank you for watching CNN.
No, seriously.
I mean, I'm
trying to wrap my mind
around some of the reporting
that's come in over the last 24 hours,
even in a statement in Mexico City.
And there were about 40 boxes
that were handed over.
And an abundance of caution
from the first batch we learned about
it doesn't necessarily
add up to ten classified docs or not
whatever level they were.
But are these new batch?
Is this from a different location
or is that part of those 40 boxes
that was handed over
a different location?
And let's just call it
an undisclosed location at the moment.
The first location was his office,
part of the Biden Pen Center
that had been sitting there
for several years.
These boxes were locked up.
My understanding is 99% of
what was in that office was personal.
It included things like
the burial arrangement documents
for Beau Biden's
funeral boxes of condolence letters
that had been sent to him
as vice president.
And that's why his personal lawyer
was going through it,
because they thought it was all personal
and confidential.
And then that lawyer gets to a box.
He opens it up.
There's a folder marked VIP, personal,
not unimportant.
He opens that up.
It says Classified
He closes it again
and he calls the White House counsel.
He says, Houston, we have a problem.
They say, call the National Archives
And that first
batch, there
were about four boxes that they found
that seemed to be different
from all the other 36 personal boxes.
And those had both
those ten classified documents
and then other documents
that were unclassified.
But fall under
the Presidential Records Act,
Sorry for the long explanation.
So it is out to me
here because it sounds like one
there's different locations, Andrew,
where things are, but also
and an abundance of caution to
then just say, here
you go, here's the whole kit
and caboodle.
Of course, the issue
and there are many issues here
is are people giving
President Biden
a pass on the idea of work this happened?
This is not the response
people had for the former
president Donald Trump.
Of course, the big distinction here
is how one behaved
once they were aware of it.
Is that a distinction that you think
should be highlighted more
It's a very significant distinction,
and particularly
in the context of the investigation
that will follow.
So is he getting a pass?
No, I don't believe he's
going to get a pass.
He's going to be investigated.
And I would opine likely
by a special counsel.
He's already better U.S.
attorney out of Illinois,
a Trump appointee. That's right.
And at this point,
I think the attorney general
would be
well advised
to appoint
a special counsel
over this investigation of how
President Biden and his team handled
these documents.
That's a separate issue.
But I think his the distinctions
between how his
he and his team have handled this
and how President Trump
and his lawyers
handled the situation tomorrow
could not be more distinct. Right.
It's it's it's night and day.
It's an overabundance of caution.
Contacting the archives immediately,
having them
come out the next day
to recover all of the documents.
There's no
parsing of, well,
you can look in this room
and not in that room
where you can look in the doorway
but not go in the boxes.
They handed everything over.
I think following in that caution,
they are now searching other locations
where documents could maybe
have ended up as well.
Contrast that to what's happening
right now in the Mar a Lago case.
You have the Department of Justice
fighting it out with Trump's
lawyers in court
to try to hold them in contempt
for failing to do exactly
what the Biden team is doing right now.
That is going out
and searching other locations.
You have the Trump
team refusing
to turn over the names
of the two private investigators
they hired to go out
and do their own search,
refusing to turn over the names
of those investigators
because they basically don't
want the department to know who they are.
So Very different reaction.
There is a cooperation on it.
So it's an important issue here.
But just for the audience,
that is it, all this, all that common.
We're hearing about it in real time
and so several months about this.
But the fact that there is,
you know, in the law,
we think about custodian of records
and chain of custody.
Is there really no one out there
who is realizing that they're missing
some of these top secret documents?
How is this continuously happening?
Yeah, I think the big picture point is
that we just need
a better system
of the United States of tracking
what happens with classified information
after the turn up,
not just a presidential administration,
but after people leave government.
Right.
So aside,
that's the big picture thing
that affects both of these presidents.
Now, as of this question, it's
a really important one.
The floor about
is a pass being given
to one party or another.
And it's really important to focus on,
at least
with former President Trump,
a federal judge had found
that there was probable cause
to believe
that there would be evidence
of a series of crimes,
including, number one,
obstruction of justice,
no to removal or mutilation of documents.
And, three,
mishandling of defense information.
And then beyond that,
there was the open question
of the amount of time,
the staggering amount of time over
several months
where the former president
and with the aid of his lawyers
was help
was allegedly frustrating
the department's investigation.
You mean the search warrant,
probable cause to certify Lago?
Yeah, outlined all of this.
And so it's just apples and oranges here.
Now, look,
we may find that
President Biden and his attorneys
are thwarting the investigation
of the Justice Department,
but that's simply not the case right now.
And if that evidence were to emerge,
of course, the president
the current president
should be investigated.
But that's just not the case.
And I think this desire to make it
one side versus the other thing,
you just can't do that to every case.
And it's just not not the case here.
We are a society that draws
distinctions, analogies
probably more often
than we should
However,
there were a lot of questions today,
and here
just a couple of them
that were asked
and of the White House press secretary,
Cohen Jean-Pierre,
that she declined to answer
who brought the documents to the office?
Did Biden himself bring them?
Why did it take so long to disclose
discovery of the public?
Was a timing
related to the midterm elections?
Were there any other things found?
Is there an audit underway?
Was he briefed? When was he briefed?
Why were the private lawyers doing this?
A number of questions
that she declined to answer
because she cited
an ongoing investigation
But that election part,
the when the people are finding out
that is going to be
something that already has legs
and might continue to run as he intends
to run for the reelection campaign.
Do you have a sense
as to why
they haven't gotten out ahead of this?
I mean, from Monday to now?
Why not just say more?
I think the issue of why wait so long
is a real issue
that's going to have
political consequences for him.
People don't like to hear this,
but this is a gift to Donald Trump
and the Republicans.
And waiting so long is part of that gift.
That said,
maybe their reasoning is
that they were cooperating
with an investigation.
I don't know.
But the political fallout is what it is.
I will say,
I don't think there's much of a chance
that Joe Biden
Kerry did these, you know, 40 boxes here.
I have a
source who is very familiar
with the documents for the record.
He is a lifelong registered Republican,
and he knows a lot
about how these things are handled
over the years.
He thinks
it was very likely an honest mistake.
The real question today is,
what are these
other new documents
that were found in these?
Your eyebrow raised
the thought of an honest mistake.
Maybe the FBI within you
was an honest mistake.
What did you say about an honest mistake?
Go ahead.
Yes, actually.
And Eliot can back me up on this.
These sort of referrals
from the National Archives
or other places about the concerns
about classified documents
that may be outside of the facilities.
They come to the department
and to the FBI all the time.
And most of them are resolved
without criminal charges.
The bureau's first concern is to find out
where is this stuff, let's get it back
and to conduct an assessment
as to whether or not
there's been damage to national security.
Have we compromised sources and methods?
Do we need to move people?
Do we need to remove technologies
from places that they are helping
us collect intelligence
And once that's done,
that's when you start thinking about
could it have been an honest
mistake, i.e.,
do we not have enough evidence
to prove the intent
to mishandled documents
that's required under those statutes?
So there will be a time for all that.
And all of these facts
that you've mentioned
are going to be a joint issue
where I come back to this point
and it's important to hear
all your perspectives.
And of course,
remember that the reason we know
about the search on Mar
a Lago and the entire course of events
between Trump
and the archives is because Trump
was the one
to have said something about it.
So maybe there was a
maybe a lesson
learned and it's gone awry. Who knows?